first of all i want to say i loved you
and the librarians i'm so sad when it
ended thank you but i'm so glad to get
to watch you in strange new worlds
was there any carry over between those
two characters for you aside from them
both being back oh my god i've been
waiting for anybody to make that
connection
um you know what between you and me yeah
just a little tiny bit um
there are similarities between those two
characters
i would say that
i mean they're both they're both brawny
and they're both very good at their jobs
and they're both
um
sticklers for
their fastidious and their meticulous
and their
their military they both have a military
background
um
i would say the big difference between
eve baird from librarians and oonachin
reilly is that una chin riley is hiding
something which of course we're not
allowed to say and i believe that she
[Music]
is fastidious and meticulous and
slightly intimidating to keep
people
at arm's length to to because she's
hiding something yes so i don't and i
don't think
eve baird wasn't really hiding anything
no but she was also a number one
basically as well basically she was a
first officer as well yeah two number
ones in a row how soon were you made
aware of the secret that we're not
allowed to talk about but how soon were
you made aware of that and did it
affect how you played the character from
that point forward yes because yes um
they the writers floated the idea to me
which made me very excited as in terms
of um character development
to have this thing that she's hiding
um
and
i think it's it's just such a nice color
to get to play um for this character who
seems like she's perfect but obviously
nobody's perfect obviously um
it's uh it was a really exciting
idea i was very excited the second they
they floated the idea um and yes it
continues to we will continue exploring
that development throughout the we're
now in season two and we're still
working it out um
i love it i love i love the color that
it adds to it to oona
excellent and what episode are you most
excited for fans to get to see this i
really i really can't say we i mean
we've now made 16 episodes and we love
them all we're so um
you know they're all they're all a
little bit different and like the
original series where standalone
episodes were not really serialized but
the funny bits are going to be funny the
horrific bits are going to be horrific
the sexy parts are going to be kind of
sexy like the original series um
i don't know i i mean personally i can't
wait for
um
the secret of my character to come out
because that's gonna continue but
it's all everybody's so good the whole
cast is so good and you know obviously
we have all of these familiar characters
that a lot of people know from the
original series and
um
there's a lot of really good character
developments i can't say which one's my
favorite
excellent well thank you so much thank
you